speaking of Fred he was on a thing we
did over the summer summer school Mehmet
felt that rassan and Gary were
aggressively complimenting Fred I loved
that by the way here's the thing so I
heard I was going to be invited as a
guest on summer school so I was like oh
let me listen to see how this sounds I
want to hear what and and the questions
they asked Fred were literally like why
are you so great when did you realize
you're so great how does it feel to be
so great you had your ass smooched for
like 40 minutes I'm not responsible for
the ass kissing well you took it though
you did accept it what am I supposed to
say you guys are wrong you guys are
[__] someone's complimenting you you
say thank you this is Mehmet uh claiming
that Fred got one big [__] onto you
your batting percentage is like as high
as it could be it's like 0.9999
listening to you talk about the drops
right now to me it sounds a lot like
LeBron James or Magic Johnson you're
using your court Vision to just guide
you as the show goes along it really
does require that type of focus and
commitment why do didn't you go to like
a good school on a scholarship like it
just seems like you're smart Fred is a
genius are you humble it really is more
of a matter of uh a discipline
best part about it is when people are
nice to you if they say something to you
it's like oh man uh Fred I love you
you're a gentleman and Fred is the one
who came up with the idea that I should
enter to the Tarantella and by the way
Fred my family loved it
it's okay the part I was really
screaming at my radio was when rasan is
comparing him to LeBron James and Fred
doesn't go that's insane he's like yeah
you're right it's the exactly
that was crazy I really thought he was
[__] with me but then I thought he
was serious and I wasn't gonna goof on
him then I get on the show and it's like
immediately it's like why do people hate
you so much why do you suck
how long have you sucked for and I was
just like what the [__] is this I
thought we were like
you know that's not what happened you
know we we had you on your immediately
you started the show combative the
second I watched in the studio before we
even started filming they're like
tearing apart my outfit saying I look
like [__] it was insane I mean how am I
supposed to perform under conditions
like that there's a montage of Mehmet
putting everyone on staff down on summer
school how would I describe you Lynette
I would say you are beloved a fan
favorite everyone but me is perfectly
content to go on the air and just ramble
on inanely and be boring I do stand
Above the Rest in a lot of different
ways what's bold is that I actually try
to comb my hair and iron my clothes and
around this office yeah everyone looks
like a slob if I was a listener and I
saw me on the street I would be like oh
my God you're fantastic I don't ever
want to cause the radio show to suck or
be bad and I feel like a lot of people
around here don't think like that
sometimes and it shows I really do kind
of look at myself as like a van Gogh
figure on the show I do think I've made
great contributions to the show and I'm
always shocked when I don't come up when
people are naming like the best people
on the show no one ever compliments me
listen you can slice moments together
what do you like to once you slice
together of us kissing Fred's ass like
that but that is true the context the
context of those clips you have to
understand again I thought I was walking
there thinking I was going to be getting
my ass kissed I was in the fight for my
life with those questions
like defend myself as a person who
exists in this world I agree with the
comment you made you are like Van Gogh
because right now you're making me want
to cut my ears off and I uh my point was
not say I'm a great artist my point is
to say I'm underappreciated which I
think okay listen I love you I don't
have anything against you in fact my men
did a really nice job I gave him the
assignment that Gary had something
called the vinyl party and he starts
telling stories about vinyl things got
so bad at this vinyl party that Gary
kept having to shush the audience
because they were interrupting and not
listening
[Applause]
we're introducing them and they're
telling their story just give them your
attention for those couple of minutes
I want to bring up our next presenter
okay can I get your attention again
just we're gonna bring our we're we're
moving very quickly so don't worry thank
you for your attention hello hello all
right we're back we're rolling we're
doing good all right thank you
all right hello hello if I can have your
attention hello thank you thank you
we're getting towards the end of the
party so if you could just give me your
patience for a couple more people I
greatly appreciate it
shut up I need to bore you some more
sure this is
showed up voluntarily hoping to have a
good time and Gary says stop it stop
having a good time and listen to me the
person who's boring you and he shushing
John Stamos and Molly Shannon I mean you
know these are people who are not used
to being shushed and when Gary shusha
you know because of the lips and teeth
configuration you get a lot of spray
coming out so the audience
oh
you know I spent like four or five days
with Gary while I was in LA to cover
this and I put together a top five list
of my top five Gary observations while I
was in LA number five I wrote it down
Gary dresses like a cartoon character
and then when I say that I mean he wears
the same outfit over and over and over
again this is like that's like from one
week on his Instagram and I did not plan
this I didn't tell him wear this shirt
and he shows up today in the shirt he
just really likes this shirt
was black one of them is blue all right
what's the fourth thing you noticed Gary
has to carry an ID card in his wallet to
let TSA agents know that he has titanium
knees I just thought that was
interesting I never knew that before my
doctor gave it to me if I ever get
stopped you have it no I carry it in my
bag what's number three Gary has one
very calloused elbow the other is
mysteriously smooth I don't know if it's
because he sits like this
so that elbow wow they're smooth oh
that's so funny you know my wife's
always talking about my I think I lean
when I'm doing the show or whatever my
desk I think I lean on one more than the
other that's true number two Gary He's
chronically late the whole week we were
in La he was late to summer school he
was late to the shuttle at the hotel oh
my God and he's never in a rush like
he's just kind of doing this talking his
sunglasses
I was late one day I completely had the
time the next day and the next no just
one time the number one thing and you
probably know this already but I have a
very specific story but then I happen to
witness myself Gary has no boundaries
when it comes to other people's food so
when this party was happening we were
told by planners Hey listen this party
they're gonna have like endless drinks
and delicious hors d'oeuvres and
delicious cookies and you the workers
are to have absolutely none of it that
is for Gary and his guests only we're
gonna provide you some lunch in like a
separate closet room so it's like okay
okay fine Gary is the talent and the
celebrities are the talent and they get
the good food so then I'm like in the
workers closet where the workers food is
and I was just shocked who is the first
person in line for that food but Gary
yeah
did I eat the last two slices of pizza
were there ten boxes left over you were
first in line I didn't see how much was
left
and then the worst part is so like the
workers are starving that night and Gary
He's full from Pizza you know because
he's eating their food and he's got like
delicious cookies he's like in their
face like taking a nibble kind of like
waving it around as he's talking and
then he like sent it on a counter we
were told like you'll be fired if you
touch a
cookie wrong you know him and I used to
have a very contentious thing and I do
feel like I consider him a friend now I
feel like we're close I'm like God I've
worked so hard to repair this
relationship and then they send me on
this final party and I have no choice
but to tell you what happened and how it
went
foreign